attualmente avete che ogni settimana sto
cercando delle scuse per non giocare
questa merda quindi questa settimana ho
trovato la scusa di mio papà perché ho
trovato la scusa di papà perché oggi ha
detto ovest i giochi sul giorni dopo che
non ci vuole bene non tocco niente più
sito direzioni su quello che devi fare
l'ebri è stato semplice perché riuscire
a fare le cose non è specifica lordi
spiego z rilasci il tuo obiettivo
pica pica aspettavo che il suo obiettivo
ridare alla fine non riscontrando
gioiosa jonica strangoli col piede ma va
anche detto cosa devo fare
scheda di cosa è il mio padre si vede un
sacco dei dati molli malati con d'età
paradigma in castello in piedi ho fatto
niente
ok devi andate vidimare tutti
commettiamo di poter devi arrivare alla
fine proteggono i candidi quindi gli
altri dal bravissimo bravissimo
[Musica]
bravissimo che ciò che facciamo fare
capito chi meno marcava non hai capito
ti giuro che deciderò se trasferirlo
bravo papà perfetto dei temi tutti gli
episodi di domenica son contento guarda
iscritto no ti faccio vedere come allora
chiede volte il continuare a con tono
ciardi che non spacchi vetro karabakh
infatti vetro devi scendere come puoi
vedere
neanche io quindi non immagino poco
tempo per farsi pagare d'età la nostra
carelli
luca ha nella che figo di tanti
riprenderla parecchie sulla rete ma è
semplice questo ok come la prendo nella
realtà per tutti brava ma bravissima
prende a scapito degli alzato le mani e
talmente con cosa le ha dato tanto in
mano lealtà farsi vedere presente sulle
maglie vito riggio chi soprano dalla
prima volta che ho capito spiega tempo
fa sono patetiche
oggi è il 38 ritiene di catania privata
cioè i movimenti labbra ma non salta un
primato del primato si fa però non
entrava nello stabile arrivi explosive
italy by con brevi vigilo pronto un ace
della mamma mia che giochi
suono c'è lo score è m'arcord quando
trovo consiste nel prendere le spade e
lanciarle con totti di preparare una
squadra così apprezzate un sinistro che
va da philippe è dovuto questo tasto
destro per la jam e lo molli quando il
lanciano perché appena bravissimo
bravissimo rimandato questo mollano
quando buon vino ti faccio un esempio to
immaginati di avere prestato da qui e
del the facendo così capisci bravissimo
meglio che ti prendo una cagata sono
quattro gli dice veramente semplice come
una sfrontata e pratichino onde se
riuscirà a farlo veramente valle vedo
con piacere che ciampi un thin film di
sfondo mi di vino che vediamo la pena
sono migliaia di totti che viaggia tutti
allora lascia un po clacson po prima
allora lasciato prima troppo vite nei
due fermate di fare una netta la è una
dieta con la prima dopo impariamo a
chiunque sbaglia mai
non mi paga mai il previamente santis
pallone perfetto uguale alluvionate
tac e 350 editori di giochi foto banali
e con una squadra di quattro feriti due
vada
in qualche modo è morto ha riposato non
lo sapremo mai come non lo so il
prossimo 99 per cento slavi obiettivo
arrivare a ritoccare rosso tua imposta
sortito un tubetto quello lascia vedere
tanti sono gli anziani che ti pare tu
devi evitare i paletti esattamente
questo vanno velocemente qua sono molto
sono molto tu devi farlo da vivo è un
livello di pigiami per me questo ma
stories of man viene toccato
ok quell episodio dentro devono proprio
di no
mettete in aria i premi adesso d'auto
prossimo presidenti se hai capito
meccanismo spetta aspettavano donna
fenomeno neymar e pato si vede l'ombra
tanto difficile complimenti gli etnei
100 x 100 x demo va di andare avanti
sull'inter di lungo corso
no però ci arrivavano detto grande di
aiutavano diritto di tutti ma come fa è
la beach ha vinto la vicevita crono
bardolino kim ha riferito come vi scrive
in posti delle regolari prove di tetra
d'età mi hanno attaccato dalla bce brava
novara in due cavalli volta maremma
aspetta dai 300 hard ad entrare lì
dentro questo te lo faccio karate do mai
inter della coppa dove di pregio ok
vai bravo bravo culo che il culo mediate
bambagia hai giocato prima col piede
quello la testa da nomi c'è il piego
queste sono bottiglie le di riprendere
come vuole fare uguale e le devi tirare
facendole rimanere cose più senso giusto
e brenda ma difficile quella volta il re
ok aver in piedi a per indietro per
protesi pesante libero ma questo video
vi sia piaciuto è stato molto bravo ma
barbara questa cosa non me l'aspettavo
così bravi complimenti
la rete non sono parenti
17 50 episodi che non ti voglio per un
territorio di una gatti che ci mettiamo
proseguito da reati
[Musica]